[Music]
this is a moment many palestinians have
been waiting for
the international criminal court
investigating allegations of war crimes
in palestinian territory including
violence against protesters
near the gaza israel fence a few years
ago
but the clearest violation of
international law is the
illegal israeli settlements in the
occupied west bank
more than 600 000 israelis live in
jewish-only settlements
killing any possibility for a future
palestinian state
it's been six years since palestine
joined the international criminal court
earlier this year the icc's chief
prosecutor received the green light from
the pre-trial chamber
confirming the court's jurisdiction over
gaza and the west bank
including occupied east jerusalem i
think that we will be encouraging the
office of prosecutor to look
at all the situation in palestine all
crimes crimes against humanity and war
crimes
and mainly the settlements regime
because there is no complementarity in
such
uh regime and this is a state policy
under the state the government
of israel policies and it's a systematic
and widespread
violation for international law ahmed
arakat's family
hopes the court brings them justice he
is one of 70 palestinians whose bodies
have been confiscated from their
families
a practice of collective punishment
a recent report by uk's forensic
architecture
says ahmed was shot and bled to death
after being denied medical treatment
israeli soldiers
killed ahmed at a checkpoint near a
buddhist town
the army said he tried to run over
soldiers
but the report says he didn't pose a
threat
they used our son as a guinea pig a
subject for their training
this is a continuing policy dozens have
been killed like this after my son
and hundreds before him
the icc's chief prosecutor says it's
also investigating allegations against
palestinian armed groups
in gaza you can't equate the oppressor
with the oppressed
the israeli occupation's policies
constitute a grave violation of
international law
but our national resistance is
legitimate
israel is not a member of the
hague-based court
prime minister benjamin netanyahu termed
the decision absurd
and anti-semitic without any
jurisdiction
it decided that our brave soldiers who
take every precaution to avoid civilian
casualties
against the worst terrorists in the
world who deliberately target civilians
it's our soldiers who are war criminals
the israeli government
says it's considering sanctioning
palestinian officials
and in response to the icc opening its
investigation
they might even advance more settlement
buildings
ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied west
bank